this week on quadriga Russia an
irrational giant russia's President
Vladimir Putin has established a new
reality with troops loyal to Moscow on
the ground in Crimea Russia doesn't
recognize the new leaders in Kiev Moscow
claims the West helped overthrow
Ukraine's legitimate government and says
the lives of Ukraine's ethnic Russians
are in danger but is this really the
case
our Putin's actions justified or are
they an audacious ploy to extend his
power the West has entered into serious
diplomatic negotiations and threatened
with sanctions but critics say
diplomatic measures alone won't deter
Putin our Putin's actions rational or
are they driven by injured Russian pride
due to the collapse of the Soviet empire
how far is he prepared to go your host
this week Melinda Crain hello and
welcome to quadriga remember the Kremlin
ologists of the old Cold War era
dedicated to decoding mysterious signals
from Moscow we've got today's version
with us here in the studio three very
astute observers of events in Ukraine
and in Russia it's my pleasure to
introduce Marcos chyme he's a political
scientist who heads the International
Security Division at the German
Institute for international and security
affairs here in Berlin and Anna Rosa
she's a Russian journalist who covers
Germany for the Russian paper roses sky
and Gazeta as well as for several other
newspapers she's also a blogger for echo
Moscow radio and Natalya shephelah she
is a political scientist from the
ukraine she's worked as a project
manager at the Center for OSCE research
and she was one of the initiators of the
Euro Maidan protests vigil here in
Berlin so I went to the trouble of
looking up the word irrational while I
was preparing for our show today and I
found such definitions as absurd
illogical lacking coherence does that
description fit anomalisa would you say
that in fact is what your country is
doing acting absurdly
I think no because President Putin is
very cute analyst who's very various men
and his actions are always very profound
and I think that he would like to reach
the scope and the scope is to defend
Russian citizens in their crane and
stabilize their secured its own o on
their Island cream so you take him at
his word when he says that's his reason
that he got this request from the former
president mr. Yanukovych that he needs
to come in to restore order and to
protect ethnic Russians you take him at
his word that Vladimir Putin really
believes that was necessary yes I think
so because at the wrong time President
Yanukovych is norm a president but it is
the illegitimate president here poorest
alleged in president of the Ukraine and
now President Putin don't understand why
there or am i down and these
revolutionists have brought this order
in the Ukraine it is not planted him
it's not it's not in the order of the
political political solving of the
problems in the Ukraine
it's don't follow the political
strategies of putting to make for
example the world think that in the
Ukraine you can break the political
order and otherwise not Natalya sharply
the Russians are saying that Yanukovych
is not remains the president that he was
not actually
the deposed by legal means and that the
new government in Kiev has not held to
its word has not held to the agreements
that were made when mr. Yanukovych left
power what do you think are some of
those arguments right and do you see
Russia as acting irrationally here yes I
see Russia as a country and putting as a
president who who act absurd since there
is no threat to Russian population in
Ukraine the president Yanukovych was
really elected by the majority of people
in Ukraine and but President Yanukovych
left country and didn't stick to the
agreement which was signed by the
foreign ministers of Germany France
Poland and in such a way he broke the
conditions of this agreement and after
that the Parliament which is at the
moment the only one led institution
which has the rights to adopt laws and
represent the interests of the whole
population in Ukraine adopted by the
majority below which which makes the
Parliament the power in Ukraine and the
majority which accepted this low
represents all parties and in such a way
it would be the
manipulating of the facts to say that
what is the the situation in Ukraine is
not legitimate and it's it's not in line
with interests of Russia of course
because to change the regime in the way
it was done in Ukraine you through the
movement it was an inside driven process
in broad set process but I think it was
a right situation and that's why I don't
agree with you sir - what - Putin's
doing is good okay two opposing views
let's let Marcus came away in here and
let's come back to those reasons that
mr. Putin himself gave in his press
conference this week he said he got a
request from former President Yanukovych
to go in to restore order and that
ethnic Russians were very much in danger
particularly in Crimea also in the
eastern part of the country what do you
think do you buy other of those reasons
I mean the argument to be invited to a
country - to implement as some kind of
military intervention is it I would say
historical dubious argument we have a
couple of cases from the from the 20th
century the Russian invasion in the
Baltic States in 1940 the Russian
intervention in Afghanistan in 1979 they
always have been pretext for something
totally different so that's I think a
dubious argument and I don't see really
a repression of the ethnic Russians in
the Ukraine and if there would be a
serious concern by the ethnic Russians
in the Ukraine I mean we have
institutions in place in the
euro-atlantic area where they can turn
to be the European Council the European
Court of Human Rights the OSCE and my
point is not to say that the situation
of those people living on the in the
Crimea is is easy but there are a set of
rules and I mean with other examples the
Russian minorities in the Baltic states
and with the help of Institute existing
international institutions we could find
a solution and therefore I didn't don't
really buy the argument and
the question to coming back to your
rationale and our question is who's rate
that are we talking about or whose
rationale are we talking about it's
definitely not the rationale of the
European Union but in if you if you
combine the Russian policy or a recall
the Russian policy of the last years I
think it fits nicely into a pattern and
the pattern is ends up with creating a
sphere of influence which is maybe not
per se anti-western but with free of
Western influence and pursuing this goal
is pretty rational in his own in the end
the eyes of the public I have two
questions I wonder where he got the
information from that there are no
repressions of ethnic Russians in the
Ukraine from the German newspapers and
the second one why do you think that
Russia has no right to protect this
population of the Crimea and the third
question is why do you think that Russia
have no right on the Ukraine because
they are not Russian citizens I mean we
have ethnic minorities oh yeah but they
are with ethnic minorities all over in
Europe I mean Romanians living in
Hungary Hungarians living in Romania but
that does not legitimate military
intervention I mean they're not citizens
of the Russian Federation similar act
similar reasons were given of course by
goodness government when he invaded the
Sudetenland in Czechoslovakia he went in
there to protect ethnic Germans is that
not an extremely destabilizing principal
on a continent where there are ethnic
minorities strewn throughout the
countries there are 60 percent of an
irrational on the island half island
Crimea and they would like to stay
together with Russia and for the first
time we have said
there are no relations or the ethnical
Russians I've got some friends in the
Ukraine and I've got some friends that
born in the Ukraine and now live in
Russia and they said that when they
speak with their friends in the Ukraine
they hear that they are really really
dangerous to stay there as Russia in the
Ukraine what are you hearing Natalia
Avila from your Ukrainian friends and
and do you know people in Crimea can can
you tell us what people are saying there
I grant it's from Crimea she lives now
in Kiev
speaks Russian the whole life and
doesn't didn't have and doesn't have
problems speaking Russian I have also
been friends in Crimea and they also
don't have any problems with the
language so in at least my friends don't
have such problems they will be not
persecuted for any reasons and somehow
Ukraine exists as an independent state
since 23 years and the the question of
language was always on the agenda during
the elections and the problem on the and
the Crimean Peninsula was also brought
to the agenda
only if the situation had to be provoked
or
provoked so I don't know one very
provocative action was taken by the new
government in Kiev as soon as it took
over power it basically annulled a law
that had been in place that made Russian
Anna second official language within
Ukraine and in Crimea was that not
rather irrational under the
circumstances I would say it was
irrational to do it by Yanukovych to
introduce this low on
the language of the of the oregano
language of minorities which allowed
Russian language to to become de facto a
second state language in the regions
where the amount of russian-speaking
people is more than 10% of things but at
the same time other languages of
minorities were not taken into
consideration so and then after the the
new government in Kiev came to power
they tried to adjust to a new lien and
to analyze this law but yeah but the
acting president turchynov vetoed it
so it's not it's not true that there is
some problems with this law since the
law since the loss is still in power and
of course after such events which we
observed in Kiev after hundreds of
people who were murdered in the streets
of Kiev people were expecting some steps
of the Parliament and the step was not
right even to speak about it I think it
was also very populist ik of the new
government to come to this question at
all but then it was vetoed and at least
at the moment there is no basis to say
that the Russian language will be to
some extent repressed Marcos crime we
have and we can see it right here on our
program two extremely different
perspectives on events in Kiev on events
in Russia in in Ukraine and very very
different reporting from the media in
Russia compared to the media here in the
West where is this in
division in perspective coming from
obviously from from a different mindset
I mean mindset not in genetic terms but
mindset in political terms given the the
political agenda of letting me poutine
which I which I just mentioned it comes
as no surprise that the dominant
paradigm of the reporting is at least
Western in Russia I mean at least
Western skeptic or even a anti Western
and given the the dominant narrative of
the Western media supporting the they're
more or less the revolutionary
government in the Ukraine it comes as no
surprise that the that the Western media
are more following the events on the on
the in Kiev and on the on the western
side of the of the of the conflict and
probably that's continued to be the case
for the for the next couple of weeks
another one of the big media events of
the week was a vitamin proteins press
conference at which at times he looked
quite uncomfortable and at which he
often gave a hint of what we in the West
might well call a siege mentality where
is that coming from a sense that Russia
is encircled that Russia is embattled
what's that about I think so
we're a situation that is really for a
situation that have provoked America for
many many many years for example they're
not or they're in the Asian in their
Eastern countries Ukraine
it's our 10-year special Donata based in
countries and this is this suckling of
the of Russia from from the from the
Western countries from the USA the US I
have made a great mistake not taken
advantage to make Russia a friend of the
USA and other NATO the natto is is
Oliver has been always an enemy of
Russia and is it stable now the enemy of
Russia because Russia and politics said
say that the US are take freely
everywhere in every pound of the world
for example in Afghanistan in Iraq in
Libyan without a resolution of the UN
and it is also very dangerous because
Russia fills itself very as the enemy of
the west and health and necessary to
defend itself from the Western military
from a USA and Canada and Russia has not
been understood from the Western
diplomats and from those politicians
because they have said Russia has a
nuclear weapon Russia is very dangerous
Russia is a bad democracy we should
share Russia the way in the future and
it is a great mistake to speak so in
this journey with Russia and the Russian
politicians and I think that Putin fills
himself as
teenager who will be oppressed from his
parents who says you it doesn't do this
right you should do this so-and-so
invasion in Ukraine it's just the
behavior of a teenager assured recently
of this charm invasion if is it invasion
politically to ridiculous and militarily
is it an invasion let's take a look at
it we have we have a short report on
where things stand militarily right now
in Crimea let's take a look the Crimean
Peninsula is effectively under Russian
military control troops loyal to Moscow
have surrounded Ukrainian military bases
and blockaded warships meanwhile Russian
President Vladimir Putin made a high
profile inspection of Russian military
war games in the Baltic
many of Ukraine's neighbors are spooked
Poland's foreign minister said Russia's
actions were an unprovoked intervention
in an independent state neither Poland
nor the world can tolerate this
we know the Predators become more and
more hungry while eating the task for
the free world is to stand against this
behavior while the West is trying to put
together a cohesive diplomatic response
Putin is following his own agenda we
should think we believe that if we make
a decision if I make a decision to use
armed forces it will be legitimate
totally corresponding to general norms
of international law the use of force in
Ukraine is not off the table so Marcus
can we just heard animals are telling us
look plenty of other times the West
marches into some country and says we're
restoring democracy we're protecting
this group or that group why is what
Putin did here any different I mean it
would have been able for him to turn to
the United Nations and put the case on
the agenda of the UN Security Council
and for reasons we cannot only speculate
about he didn't do so and then would
have been the proper way if he feels or
if he considers the situation in the
Ukraine or the situation between Ukraine
and Russia and a threat to international
peace and security which also comprises
domestic instability and that would have
been an option but for national
political reasons he didn't do so and I
think he said the Russian government is
applying a double standard I mean
currently the Russian leadership is
emphasizing self-determination but the
way the east central Eastern European
countries decided independently to turn
to the European Union to turn to the u
NATO is perceived in Moscow some kind of
seed but the same argument
self-determination is currently used by
the Russian leadership with rotten
situation from here
if Russia does feel somewhat besieged is
there perhaps not some good reason for
that
NATO promised at the time of the fall of
the wall that it would not move into the
former countries of the Warsaw Pact and
yet it did there our NATO bases right on
Russia's doorstep is that not a problem
do you think we did not keep our
promises that were made at the time of
the end of the Cold War in the West
moreover your country Ukraine has always
had very very close ties with Russia and
Russia of course has that crucial Navy
base in Crimea was it naive to think
that Russia would simply stand by under
those circumstances if Ukraine tilted
very definitely not only toward the EU
but also toward NATO mmm I would say yes
it was the misjudgment of the possible
direction of Russia on the knot
extension and also on the policy of the
European Union Union towards Ukraine and
but it does not justify the position of
Russia and what is happening in Ukraine
and another remark on one side concern
your comment that Russia is almost
excluded from the international
community in the sense that all try to
say what Russia has to do but it's it's
also not true since since the collapse
of Soviet Union the the Western
countries try to involve Russia in all
organization which has the name to
stabilize the euro-asian region so
Russia is the member of all organization
there are common projects
in different areas arms control
disarmament and so on so I wouldn't say
that the Western countries treat Russia
is a small browser it's not true all
respect to the nuclear power state which
Russia is and but to understate the
intention of Russia or direction of
Russia in case of Ukraine it was a
little bit naive since we already
experienced the revolution in Ukraine
2004 and Russia erected to really calm
so to say on what happens in Ukraine but
it was ten years ago and it was another
go political situation in the world and
we had another Russia and Putin was also
another person to tell the truth the
person who we had a lot of hopes
concerning Russia under Putin so to say
yes I'm remembering remarks both of
President George Bush and also of
Gerhard schröder
who said that he believed poutine to be
an absolutely spotless Democrat and a
Xhosa
let's start looking at where things go
from here we've heard some very clear
voices in Europe particularly right here
in Germany which has been playing a very
very active mediating role saying look
Russia has to be part of the solution an
outreach toward Russia a very strong one
coming from the Foreign Minister
frank-walter Steinmeier who has said all
along we cannot fall back into old Cold
War ways of thinking how responsive is
your country to those messages I've
heard that the President Putin has said
that and Minister Lavrov
said that they would like to elaborate
solution for this conflict together was
where some countries but otherwise the
Russian population don't what take the
Ukraine in don't what I want health
Ukraine together with the Russia because
Ukraine is economical Avella very very
sorry
weak and because it costs a lot of money
for Russia it has cost a lot of money
for Russia for 20 years do something
about public opinion on that point and
in general last week we also did a
program here on Ukraine and we had three
guests telling us look what Russia is
doing is very much about domestic
consumption about appealing to people
inside of Russia let me ask you this I
realize Russians on the basis of their
history are very very sensitive about
revolutionary turmoil it makes them
nervous but frankly doesn't seeing their
country get involved militarily in a
neighboring country with all the
potential that creates for violence and
turmoil isn't that at least as worrisome
for them I think that now Russian
politician would like have war on the
borders of Russia and I think that is an
unrealistic to say that there will be
war on the Crimea or otherwise because
it weakness the Russia itself and it is
economically very bad for Russia in this
economical financial situation because
their economics results now shows that
Russia has very bad ratings now
economical ratings and I think that
President Putin understands it and don't
like directing Russia involving itself
in the conflict with air cranes
Marko's comb is it possible that the
status quo that we have right now might
suit Vladimir Putin and Russia just fine
we get to bail them out
with 15 billion I think the EU is now
offering 11 billion the u.s. offering a
couple billion as well so we get we in
the West get to bail them out and the
Russians they have their forces right
there in Crimea where they can be a
continuing thorn in the side of Kiev and
possibly that way ensure continuing
Russian influence does that sound like a
quite rational scenario for the Russians
maybe not rational but I think it's
highly likely that it will develop
exactly the way that it the way you
indicated it the the referendum in on
the Crimean Peninsula will take place in
March end of month and I haven't read
the precise questions so far but I would
be surprised if it's really about
independence but more were the more
about a very strong autonomy within the
Ukraine probably the Russians Federation
will not withdraw their military
contingent it will remain there for in
an illegal perspective in a legal
perspective the Crimean answer will
remain part of the Ukraine however it
will be a fact or maybe not part of
Russia but part of the Russian sphere of
influence and therefore will have
another one of the so-called frozen
conflicts and I absolutely agree with
you that that provides that gives
guarding they're put in the the highest
amount of political leverage Natalia
shillelagh what's the Ukrainian
assessment where do people in your
country see this heading and what needs
to happen now first of all the people in
Ukraine are still shocked because of
what happened in February it should be
said here in this round we should not
forget that the people were killed by
snipers and
and we will not go in the discussion
into the discussion on this issue but I
think it's fair to mention hundreds of
people who are know that and that's why
coming back to your question or what
what happens now is regarded through the
prism of the recent events and any
further confrontation or a conflict
escalation it's not what people in
Ukraine want they don't want to have war
since the memories of the Second World
War I would not say fresh but they are
very deep in the conscious of every
Ukrainian person and it's the worst
scenario to have a war or military
conflict on the territory of Ukraine and
the scenario we just discussed yeah I
groups present there no conflict no open
hot conflict but a cold division I it's
also the scenario which I see which can
be performed in Ukraine and we there is
also there are also other examples in
Georgia in model we have enough frozen
conflicts and Russian hands
unfortunately are in all these conflicts
and so I would not exclude it we have
another frozen conflict on the territory
of Ukraine which will not allow Ukraine
to be a member of NATO since no country
with internal conflicts can can become a
NATO member and that is again coming to
the previous question it's the aim of
Russia to to not to allow Ukraine in the
short long perspective to be a NATO
member since in
it will move for the nature closer to
the Russian borders being realistic
Ukraine was never going to become a full
member of NATO in any way and it was a
could this not become a lose-lose
situation for mr. Putin I must say
during his press conference he wasn't
looking exactly relaxed and happy about
the whole situation and the fact is
Russia at the moment has a very weak
economy it badly needs investment and
trade from the West it badly needs to be
selling as much gas as it possibly can
that pipeline goes right through Ukraine
to Europe if Ukraine were to sabotage
the pipeline or even shut it down in the
summer months that could all redound
very much to the disadvantage of Russia
where do you see things heading and is
this possibly not irrational after all
in the sense that there are no very good
options out there for mr. Putin yes it
is not very good option if I'm where
supporting and he realized there's
completely I think is very real
political but the but Russia does it as
they we saw has done there is law at the
time with little countries with
invasions and with military solutions of
the conflicts and Russia fills itself as
in the time of the Cold War
as the USA was the enemy and it is not
about the Ukraine now it is about this
conflict between their west and Russia
between the USSR and Russia and I think
it would be good for all of us for this
great countries be countries the result
Russia and the European Union also too
- gar the way of fighting their
solutions together for Russia brother
you were saying for the Ukraine one of
the interesting aspects of this crisis
has been the different sort of
statements coming out of my own country
the u.s. compared to your country Marcos
crime Germany we're hearing a lot of
cold war style rhetoric out of the u.s.
not necessarily from President Obama so
much but certainly from former Secretary
of State Hillary Clinton to some degree
from the current Secretary of State John
Kerry his State Department just issued a
point-by-point rebuttal for instance of
Vladimir Putin's claims and on the other
hand German politicians as I said
earlier making a very big effort to
build some kind of a bridge between
Russia and the West including for
example proposals of the contact group
are you satisfied is that going further
far enough and what would you want to
see the West do differently I think as
the German citizens I'm pretty pretty
happy with my government I mean not not
so much in substance but that it
provides something provides engagement
provides commitment to contribute to
some kind of conflict resolution and
given that I mean the presence of a
quieter time together with this French
and polish colleague I think wasn't was
a useful effort I mean the the what has
been accomplished boss has never
materialized
however I think it's it's it's good to
provide something but we have to keep in
mind that even the German politicians or
the term political class but has for a
variety of reasons and political early
open to Russian concerns for four years
it has become more it's phrased sober
about what can be accomplished with
Russia I mean a couple of years ago
everybody was talking about strategic
partnership with Russia modernization
part that nobody using it that anymore
and so there's a way more realistic
approach and therefore I think in my
view one of the disadvantages or prizes
the Russian policy has to pay is a way
huge reputational loss here in in Berlin
and in a very a variety of European
capitals as well Natalia Shephelah you
agreed that it's quite possible we might
see this turn into a frozen conflict is
that something that people in your
country would tolerate would we be
likely to see things in that case like
sabotage like perhaps some kind of Maria
actions by other forces where where do
you see your country heading with this
and what kind of support can they
realistically ask for and expect it's a
good question we can predict a lot of
things but something unpredictable so to
say that Ukrainian people are not used
to to fight actually and during the last
month it was the first time in the
history of the independent Ukraine that
people used not only words but also some
other means to fight for for the aims so
I would not exclude that there is some
conflict potential inside of Ukraine but
combined with the European attempts to
stabilize the situation combined with
the economic situation which is really
really very weak and the fact that we
are fully dependent on the foreign aid
at the moment I think it's an argument
for Ukrainian people maybe to tolerate
the solution which will be suggested by
the mediators European
American mediators so I think now it's
really a diplomatic case and people of
Ukraine will accept the thing which will
be suggested to them if if the if
Ukraine will will still stay a sovereign
country with Grimm as a part of it
Crimea is and there goes our two
questions here a one question coming
back to that contact group a proposal
that Germany is made because there's
been very little direct communication
between Kiev and Moscow so far there was
an opportunity this week it was not
taken up Sergey Lavrov and the new
foreign minister of Ukraine were in the
same building at the same time did not
speak to each other because mr. Lavrov
did not want to speak first of all do
you think that contract group could
bring us closer to some kind of solution
secondly Ukraine desperately needs money
as we know is there a scenario out there
where Russia actually becomes part of
the package part of the solution for the
first time this contact group that has
been built from Sikorsky Fabio santanaya
has got no results the results that has
got this group wasn't an agreement an
agreement has not been been subscribed
and it's our word now let us not look
back going forward okay forward the
future Canton group will be the only
solution for this conflict I think but
the problem is that Russian government
doesn't think that the government in the
Ukraine is legitimate because there are
some people that are from the
nationalistic
in parties more as a half of this
government or the Ukraine has been one
sentence because we're about to run out
of time money
can you imagine Russia's giving money as
part of a general package I I think so
yes yes yes if this government of the
Ukraine would be legitimized Russia will
they give the money thank you very much
I'm afraid we're out of time but I'm
sure we'll have opportunities in future
to pick up the subject again thanks to
all of you for being here thanks to you
out there for tuning in